[Music]
starting first thing with an epileptic
water slide everything's tasting
turquoise what is this just watch
Marvel's entire television strategy
somehow makes it into the episode Hi
boss fancy game of chess chess chess
chess we get it you want us to know it's
a smart person so you show us chess just
once I'd like to see a genius bust out
clue or mouse trap you didn't just help
it was you who commanded the Army wow RN
Slayer leading an army during a Time war
that sounds really cool I'm glad we just
get to see people talk about it for a
few seconds instead of the actual
conflict really saved us some time we
might have spent enjoying something did
they not teleport back to the TVA
together at the end of the last episode
why is Victor wandering around
unescorted letting a mad scientist roam
around your high tech facility
unsupervised seems like a good way to
turn said mad scientist into a cosmic
level threat is that
my and you're the only one who can help
us fix it well not the only one he does
have like thousands of other variants
who could all take a whack at it too
this is just the only other king this
Series has bothered with what are the
people working on in the background here
the TVA basically stopped doing its job
why do they all look so busy so I built
all of this or I did well or I will and
I did being self-aware of your own timey
Wy BS doesn't make it any less b or s
but I learned everything I know from a
brilliant 19th century inventor named
Victor timley so Victor taught OB
everything he knows but everything
Victor knows came from a TV handbook
that he was given by Ren Slayer and she
was sent to deliver the book by an AI
created by he who remains which is a
future version of Victor maybe usually
if I'm expected to excuse a bunch of
time nanigans it comes from a more
Charming person like David Tennant and
as Disney already wasted him on Ahsoka
I'm left with no excuse but to sin all
this nonsense Mr or would you inscribe
my my handbook only if you inscribe mine
show about running out of time somehow
does not run out of time for this
integrating them if that would even work
would take a long time so why don't just
go back to the past where you have
plenty of time assemble it and then
bring it back to the present why does
this show forget how accessible time
travel is to these people you dragged me
back here begging for help no no they
did not you let them take Victor and
then they left no begging took place at
all in fact it's a wonder you even
returned to the TVA when you've shown no
interest or help in solving their
biggest problem I don't want to die in
here well it seemed like you gave up
when you sold out our plan how did he
give up you sold out your plan with the
understanding Mobius and Loki would
return him to the sacred timeline to be
an actor it's not giving up that's
cutting a deal for self-preservation the
very opposite of giving up actually I
earned my life sure Brad but how did you
earn this much screen time though I'm
genuinely curious two people just
stepping into a cell filled with
prisoners you're just begging for a
jailbreak I know they all have collars
on but I forget what those even do and I
refuse to look it up if we have to fight
to defend this place from Ren Slayer or
worse can we trust you no offense to Doc
Brad or the Minuteman but I don't really
care about what happens to them this all
just feels like a writer's room forcing
a b plot in order to fill a hole in the
show and forcing things into holes can
be painful I took a wrong turn didn't
plan on coming to Pand at least P land's
a real place I was once told I'd win a
trip to cakeland and that turned out all
be a lie fcking glattus are all of these
pies key lime no apple No Blueberry no
chocolate or pumpkin H I'd even take a
strawberry rhubarb to get some variety
up in here you're only here because you
couldn't kill him that's pretty faulty
logic if she couldn't kill Victor what's
being in the TVA change is she hoping to
work up the courage to kill him later
kind of seems like the show is just
looking for an excuse to keep another
Loki around all those dead branches
those dead
people that's the tva's fault what about
those branches I'm really struggling to
care about those branches because the
season didn't bother to show us any of
those people disappearing so we could
witness how devastating it is to lose
those timelines once again this show
Fast forwards through an interesting
concept so two characters can mention it
in passing and move on to the next MCU
plot Point sounds like whatever we do
we're playing God we are Gods Loki isn't
Dawning a pair of Shades as the who
plays after that line and you this is
really disappointing I must say I know
I'm working on myself
okay I love Miss minutes sure she gets a
bit creepy but her bless your heart and
what I mean by that is you attitude
really resonates with
me you have full-on time technology and
the best way you can think of to torture
and kill people is through a shrinking
Cube what was the goal to do it in the
messiest way possible or the most
inefficient Kudos on somehow
accomplishing both also again my problem
with this scene is that all of the
minimin seem irrelevant voiceless and
almost indifferent they're just
background to make this scene more
horrific the only real char character
being killed here is Doc and after four
episodes I'm honestly not sure she even
counts spacular yeah it is spectacular
that the device you designed had a
perfect opening for Victor's little part
you didn't know existed 10 minutes ago
wait is spectacular a synonym for
[__] I get confused sometimes you
have a machine for that the man who
invented a machine to process multiple
timelines across reality is suddenly
surprised there's another machine that
heats chocolate powder and makes it
taste like poop in a cup yeah I said it
hot cocoa is a stupid beverage you want
some chocolate eat aing candy bar in
fact hot cocoa tastes like a
rant show about running out of time
somehow doesn't run out of time for
this how did timely not see Brad sneak
up on them before before he turned
around is Bradley Batman sorry wrong
universe is Bradley The Flash that hot
coco is lukewarm by now at best and if
you thought hot chocolate was bad wait
till I tell you about lukewarm
choc stealing your plot and dialogue
from Dennis nedre and you'd best be
careful about pissing him off when you
control the mail you control information
it's got to be R oh no if only you
hadn't stranded her at the end of time
with a device that would allow her to
immediately open a portal and return to
the TVA and right now you're going to
tell us where to find your device why do
they want the device though it's obvious
Loki and Mobius brought timely to the
TVA to fix the loom should they just
stand back and wait for them to finish
and then take control is that not a good
idea or am I just really lazy she's
trying to slow us down take the stairs
forcing Hulk to take the stairs at
endgame was what started this entire
series do we really want to risk sending
Loki to do the exact same thing what if
he causes more Rifts that become
mediocre Disney Plus
Series this
works called it and when even I can call
it it's definitely a sin I promise you
this will make sense it will not I'm
being you're an all- knowing AI so why
didn't you lock everyone's admin access
except for your own when you gain
control of the system why are
intelligent characters written to make
such dumb mistakes I need to tell
you
you'll never be him stating the obvious
nobody can be him except for him not
moojo not the Rowdy Ruff Boys not the
amoeba boys they all pale in comparison
of how creepy him was and Victor
certainly can't hope to compete with
such a scary villain I'm a grown ass
adult with a mortgage and him still
terrifies me to this day what were we
talking about again evil Rogue AI
defeated by turning it off and on again
that's new is it the lights have been
flickering on and off for about four yep
four episodes now go go go where is
there a fuse box on that floor that he
knows about why are you getting rid of
your muscle just because the lights went
out that's the second time in two
episodes Rin Slayer has been sent to the
end of time it's almost like the whole
pruning thing is completely meaningless
as punishment we have to move fast fast
fast or slowly get another cup of hot
chocolate fast I want to know how
prepared I should be for actual
excitement that's the face of a man
realizing he probably should have used
his magic in some way or another
temporal radiation is just too high you
are the last person who should be
surprised by
that wow gutsy move on Marvel's part
into season finale with the protagonist
losing and everyone dying I might have
to rethink my earlier criticism and
what's that there's still two more
episodes damn
it your mother still makes lousy
spaghetti so we forgive and forget you
want forgiveness get religion all right
what's the plan all day I don't know
what the heck is going on but somehow
this feels like it's all my fault how
does it feel knowing that all of us here
would rather die than follow you out
that door I'm from buen series and I say
kill them all look at me look at
me it was
me
oh that's not right